i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman is so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
[Music]
[Music]
the power of all the gods
this is very personal binny
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
the furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was the signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is
[Music]
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
i just threw a truck and a dragon i love
my life
can i get a witness